K pour le 454 merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre je vous
sais sensible aux investissements dans
les entreprises c'est d'ailleurs au nom
de cela que vous baissez de manière
systémique et systématique les impôts de
production depuis des années une étude
de l'OFCE montre que suite à la réforme
française de 2013 la hausse de
l'imposition des revenus du capital a
incité les entreprises à moins verser de
dividende de fait l'argent a été en
partie réalloué vers des investissements
pourtant à rebours des conclusions de
cette étude la formule que vous avez
transformé en mantrra et bien connu en
baissant la fiscalité sur le capital les
plus aisés seront incités à investir
c'est d'ailleurs votre seul argument
pour justifier la réforme du début du
précédent mandat consistant à remplacer
l'ISF par l'IFI qui ne cible plus que le
patrimo Mo immobilier et l'instauration
du pfu de 30 % sur les revenus
financiers selon l'étude mené par
Charles Boissel et Adrien matre pour le
National Bureau of Economic Research
pour chaque euro de dividende non
distribué les entreprises concerné ont
réinvesti 0,30 centimes d'euros elles ne
l'ont pas fait n'importe comment elles
ont augmenté davantage les
investissements uniquement lorsqu'elles
avaient d'importantes opportunités
d'investissement on peut on peut donc
aisément conclure que entreprises ne
sont pas prêtes à à gaspiller leurs
revenus non distribués lorsque les
retours sur investissement attendus sont
limités alors comment justifier le
maintien de cette flat taxe France
stratégique vient de citer mon collègue
a remis son rapport en 2021 dans lequel
je cite elle indique que l'instauration
du pfu n'a pas conduit les entreprises
dont les actionnaires ont bénéficié du
pfu à connaître une évolution
d'investissement significativement
différent de celle des autres pire le
pfu a favorisé l'augmentation et la des
dividendes en effet en 2017
01 % de contribuable percevit la moitié
des dividendes soit 7,6 milliards
d'euros c'est donc soucieux de rétablir
une capacité d'investissement stable de
nos entreprises et dans un souci de
rétablissement d'une plus grande justice
fiscale et sociale que je vous propose
de supprimer cette flat
taxe